welcome to this video plane Catwoman
Catwoman from Spain down let's see you
huh benoni okay let's play now in a more
conservative fashion it's often actually
quite a good idea against the Benoni
players no no I go for that why not the
bishop is misplaced on b7 so we haven't
been only after all and he actually won
a temple because I play e3 e4 but b6
Bishop e7 is so bad at the end he
probably has to play a bishop c8 back so
so I'm basically I'm the one with the
temple game okay maybe I can exchange
the bishop I chief form yeah but 95 I
can just take this is Sir not wow this
looks like completely unplayable just er
f6 rookie five yes still I cannot really
believe that you can allow a pawn to be
established on f6 it has this block only
five but still how to how to play that
the night should go to see for this much
is clear probably be 3z phone
orgy fall for that matter is also a good
square but this was the original
intention the Sun wins the exchange at
least the rook simply has no square to
go to go to the question is so do I want
to take it or as to something better
even I cannot really move any of those
pieces gee 5v5 is not really a helping
move I I think I play even g45 here
completely completely a sealing the
kingside you can play g5 but this this
really Evans I don't don't believe it
ok so now the rook still cannot move I
can take it later I want let's first
prepare play on there on the spawn a
queen is three we can play Queen III I
can take on d5 l'd like to get I can I
can move the Queen right okay but I
don't want to allow Luke takes d4
and hmm i don't know maybe okay i was
thinking if i have something something
better than the grabbing they exchanged
it is it gives him a good square one a
night but it's it's just an exchange
relief he doesn't have any compensation
or anything okay let's see it's
difficult to to make any progress alone
this is son this is some a clear problem
and it's got Queen g6 coming
hmm
hmm not easy at all damn I had my doubts
about taking only five maybe this was
really a mistake it's a it's not not
easy at all an hour to play oh no I have
any five and this this I will play
whatever the cost yeah I know it's
winning yeah it wasn't so it wasn't so
clear really I don't know after i took
the exchange this was some was a bit
shaky not cleared how to how to actually
win the game gets probably probably more
than one good move queen is looking
towards h7 of course
yeah I'd like to detect g5 with Queenie
three on something like that
93 I can take a six and then f7 hope
this that adds this n take sign f7 point
is Luke f6 check if he goes Queen f8
what's probably the only move have to
check and Ruby six check check so let's
check is there some better move then
Luke g8 no probably not maybe there is
okay let's let's do that lang at least
he's got a couple of poems now
and now I needs to give up the night
because of the pin there should be three
check check
b3 rupee 8 and now this check yeah i
think i'll i'll be able to check to earn
time morning set the rookie for the
three pawns and then when the King
opponent game check check check mate
yeah it was interesting because this
night xe5 was really debatable I wasn't
sure at all if I should do that I mean
me maybe g4 is even debatable if I take
it I probably should take it now the
computer has a cool idea here look a 3b
three winning winning the pod this is
very good actually the very interesting
idea okay i don't think that g4 is
really bad but maybe here I probably
really shouldn't take funny enough the
computer also doesn't want to take i
mean if i want to take i can take it in
any at any moment but okay I first
rejected to take it and then I simply
didn't didn't see how to how to improve
but interesting computer Queen III yeah
i was thinking about this move but I saw
Luke t5 but i think probably I can just
take it on no look f5 one's interesting
yeah of course design I didn't see very
very well very strong of course for
white thread
this amongst others okay yeah so it was
a mistake to take the exchange I mean
white white should win but it's it said
it has helped like in some way yeah I
know this was you should never ever
allow the blockades to be lifted so you
must must take him and while white shirt
should win it's not it's not so clear
cut as in the game yeah I'm just I'm
just breaking through did I have some
other way rook takes g5 is checkmate
okay maidenform yeah it's very nice
actually Luke age five meat is the idea
it takes here check checkmate that's
cute alright hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching